So I'm just want to go back
very briefly to Hemingway's.
Um, leather to dawn does pass.
It was just two reminders.
Um, what we, um,
are up against this claim
on Hemingway's pot. Um,
and there's this,
George Kaufman is here and she
claims they want to cut it all out.
Indian Cam story because the
ENL time chapters, Jesus,
I view our sharp to how about it?
Of course they can do it because the
stuff is so tight and hard and everything
hands on everything else. So you know,
this is the um, very recognizable,
a pasture on the part of Hemingway
that everything is tight and hot and
everything hangs on everything else.
So,
but giving the publication history of um,
the various chapters and also the stories
published separately, um, you know,
whether or not there is in fact,
um, and organic unity among them.
There's the big question.
And last time, um, you know,
we try to give him the benefit of the
doubt and we read the intro chapters and
the stories as they've, they
were indeed organically, um,
integral, um, to one another.
So today will, um, try that.
Try a, some other combinations. Uh,
but I found this picture of
Hemingway and those parcels.
Um,
so you know,
Hemingway is to the far right and
there's those parcels to the far left.
And, um, I was always loved this. Um, and,
and they actually both rolled about war.
Those parcels has a novel called
three novels, a three soldiers, uh,
very, very, uh, great novel
about war as well. So, you know,
you can sort of see that they
have a lot in common. Um, and um,
here's another input in a
leather, uh, two M and Wilson. Um,
this is, um, slightly earlier, um,
finish the book of 14 stories with a
chapter in our time between each to give
the picture of the whole
between examining it in detail,
like looking with your eyes as something,
say a passing coastline and then looking
at at it with 15 x binoculars or rather
than maybe looking at it and then going
in and living in it and then coming out
and looking at it again,
it has a pretty good unity.
So once again, that all important word
for having way, um, pretty good unity.
And that's a very strong claims, not
really pretty good. It's damn good. Um,
but in any case, uh, was all with
new about this, um, description,
um, is the idea of zooming
in, zooming out rate.
This is very much the approach
that we've been taking. Um,
and we've been thinking of it in
terms of micro and macro rate.
So this, um, the first set of
terms that we started out with,
um, and today I'd like
to add a few more terms.
There's also line up, um, in kind of
similar way, obviously not the same,
um, but they are kind of
interrelated. So micro, macro,
um, obviously up close from a
distance, um, before and after.
That's especially important when
the soldiers coming back home. Uh,
what happened during a war,
what happened after the war, um,
and going along with that intensity of
the experience when you're in the war and
as we know from the story.
So it was just home,
the staleness of it when you come back.
Um,
and then another pair of Toms is very
important to our class actually is trategy
and comedy. Um, since
this is all writing class,
I also wanted to stop for just one
minute and talk about this as a kind of a
useful, uh, analytic and
organizational structure to use,
um, in your papers. Um,
so start out with one pair of analytic
terms and then try out the various
variations of that term, um,
in the course of the paper. Um,
and that will give you a really
tight structure is that there's what,
how many weight ones? Um,
so I'll explain this more,
but just keep this in your mind. Um,
you know, thing of your papers, um,
as theme and very Asian use,
inventing different terms, um,
that would allow for that
theme and variation structured.
So we talk more about the
substance of implication of that.
But for now, I think that this is
really what Hemingway himself, um,
is doing because such a great writers,
good example to us. Um, so anyway,
um,
the for today we'll be looking
at for a possible clusters,
you know, want to emphasize that
these are just conjectural clusters.
Um, we can test them. Um,
the first one is a chapter
seven and soldiers home.
Uh, and then we'll be looking at
chapter nine and Mr and Mrs. Elliott,
hilarious story. Um, chapter
10 and cat in the rain.
And then chapter 12, um, and
bake two hearted river, part two.
Um, so first chapter
seven, um, once again,
we're back in wartime Europe.
The experience of combat, uh,
while the bombardment was knocking
the tranche two pieces f Asada,
he leave very flat and sweated
and pray, Oh, Jesus Christ,
get me out of here. Dear Jesus, please
get me out. Jesus, please, please,
please Christ
the shelling.
Move further up the line.
We went to work on a trend and in the
morning the sun came up and the day was
hot and muggy and cheerful and quiet.
Then that's night back at Maestra.
He did not tell to go.
He went upstairs with at
a villa Rosa about Jesus,
and he never told anybody.
So this is the suit of the class
dynamics of before and after,
and the intensity of the experience when
you're in the thick of the battle and
the sense that you really
have lost it all, um,
ones that experience is behind you.
Um,
so what Hemingway is exploring
here and that he would,
we'll see you also explore in
greater length in soldier's home.
Um,
is that in transitive relation of
emotions across time is a terrible thing.
Um,
you know,
we think so much about the question of
sustainability is important for things to
be sustainable across time.
Um,
and it seems that Hemingway is saying
they're basically intense emotions are not
sustainable across time.
And we'll see it as in a big way,
Ashley in Faulkner, in the sound,
the fury in the Quentin section,
whether or not we're even when
we're devastated by something,
whether or not that sense of devastation,
uh,
will be with us even a
short moment afterwards. Um,
so it seems that when he's
fearing, you know, in,
in this kind of more a fear
for his life, um, Jesus,
um, and that's really a kind of
a name for something. You know,
it's not necessarily Jesus, although
in this case it actually is Jesus.
But Jesus could also be a shorthand for
something that we really want just to
invoke. And it's very much a
presence for is that moment.
And then the meaning of
Jesus has completely lost
even the next night. Um, so,
um, was, was, was interesting
and I guess quite bleak about is,
um, is that we really can hold on to
our own experience. Right? You know,
we'd like to think that if
we've been through this,
that is ours for good is ours for life.
Um,
and it seemed snap to the case. So, uh,
let's move on now to soldiers
home. Um, and you know, we,
no, um, I'm just realizing that
Mike is all the way down. Um,
we know that there's crabs was a soldier
fighting in basically all the famous
battles in world war one. Um, and then he,
he comes home too late.
So by which time,
all the other people have been bad in
that Italian stories about war atrocities.
So, you know, there were these listening,
um, to him anymore. Um, and his mother's,
she was worried that he should
find a job. Um, so this is,
um, the, the very, um, near the middle,
just one line near the middle of
the story that having breakfast,
a craft is reading the papers and
learning about, um, you know, um,
his father not wanting to
people to be roughed up. Um,
and then meanwhile perhaps looked at
the bacon fat hardening on his plate.
Um,
and I think that that is in some sense
the most graphic metaphor for the
Hemingway has come up with material
emblem of our own relation to our own
experience. That this is the chemical
transformation, you know, is so natural.
I mean, last time we talked about the
naturalization of pain, right? You know,
childbirth is as natural as rain and the
pain that we inflict on all of this is
also as natural as rain. Um, and here, um,
for fresh experience to go stale,
it is as natural as the bacon
becoming stale on your plate.
Um, so that's just kind of, uh, you
know, using a very common object,
um,
to talk about the fate
of emotions across time.
Uh, and the fact that to go on living, um,
is not accumulative.
Um,
there's a loss and tell the longer you
live mean this is a terrible thing.
You know, we like to think that
some things can be cumulative,
but according to this paradigm,
um,
it's almost as if the longer you live,
the more you lose actually.
And we know that Hemingway actually
chose to end his own life, right?
So this is almost a kind of, um, I mean,
he wasn't thinking of suicide at
that point at this early point,
but it's almost a justification for
suicide that you want and it at the moment
of greatest intensity and prayers,
emotional satisfaction,
you don't want to lose
that. Um, so there's that.
The Bacon fat hardening on his plate.
Um,
and then the very,
and of the story,
well that was all over now anyway,
he would go over to the school yard and
watch how and plate indoor basketball.
Um, no detail is trivial.
No detail is random. Well,
not always, but quite often, I mean, you
know, this is very significant is how, um,
in Hemingway, um, and is once,
it's almost the kind of, um,
uh, kind of a larger, um,
slightly larger view of moving away
from the bacon fat on the plate to the
larger family situation.
Um,
craps was a very good
soldier during World War One.
He's not a very efficient player
instead of Lillian life, right?
Helen is the players just
in the early the basketball,
basketball player,
but she's also a player in a bigger sense.
It's just more consequential in
life than Krebs ever would be.
Uh, and it's the sadness of being
consequential, been Ali consequential,
important,
very good at what you're doing in
one context and being terrible being,
you know,
not attended to and not listen to,
uh, being completely on
the side lines once, uh,
you put in a different kind of situation.
So crabs is on the sidelines,
a mere spectator,
um,
as Helen plays both the indoor basketball
and also the game of life that he's
probably not going to be very good
at. Um, so obviously that these,
I think these two stories, um,
the connection between them very,
very tight. Um, you know, they
are in two different settings,
but they really are making
your sadly the same point. Um,
so let's move on now to more interesting,
kind of not so quite so clear cut,
uh,
between chapter nine. Um,
and Mr and Mrs. Elliott. Uh,
so it's,
um,
in many ways the kind of Hemingway
that we're very familiar with,
the Hemingway in the sun also rises to
Hemingway who talked about bar fights and
he also does it in a death in the
afternoon. Um, so this is, um,
the kind of classic
Hemingway. Um, the first,
except there's a twist here.
Um,
the first matador got the horn through
his sought hand and the crowd who did
him,
the second matador slip and the
ball court in through the belly,
he hung onto the horn with one hand and
how the other tight against the place
and a ball rammed him
where am against the wall.
And a horn came out and he lay in the
sand and then got up like crazy drunk and
tried to slug the man carrying him out,
carrying him away and yeah, offers,
sought the,
he fainted.
The kit came out and had to kill five
balls because you can't have more than
three. Matadors. Um, you know,
this is the emotion I think that actually
is the dominant emotion in, in no time.
This isn't exactly tragedy.
It doesn't rise to the level of tragedy,
but it's not exactly funny eater.
And this is really the combination
of the tragedies, lash, comedy, um,
that is so important to having way.
Um,
nobody gets killed except for
the ball five of them. Um,
but that's supposed to happen.
Um,
the first would be to completely
incompetent and matadors.
Um, they're making a fast,
really of the ball fight.
Um,
and meanwhile it's also farcical in a
different way that you have to split by
the roofs.
Even the two first two matadors
and a complete mess of everything.
Um, you still have to go by the rules.
So he can have more than three matadors.
And so one single person is to kill five
balls because after Roe, um, so, you know,
this is the kind of the combination.
We don't know whether to laugh or to cry.
Um, and, um, I guess we laugh, uh,
because it's not worth crying over,
but it really is not that funny.
And this is the nature of
the kind of very complicated,
dark,
um,
kind of comedy that we get in Hemingway
and that will be getting in Fitzgerald
and Faulkner as well. So this is really
the common ground. Very interesting.
Um, compounding of Java is usually, uh,
we used to thinking of tragedy and comedy
as two discrete John is quite Sanford,
right? But in American literature, um,
I mean this is really goes back to the
19th century in American literature.
Quite often there's the kind
of a mixing of John Arras, uh,
with tragedy,
uh,
been energized Ashley by comedy
and producing really interesting,
a kind of experimental
Jara. Um, so, okay, so that,
keep that in mind as
well. Both fighting, um,
and in competent matadors and then
the kid having to clean up the mess.
So it's with seem on the face of it,
it was seemed that that really couldn't
have any relation to Mr and Mrs.
Elliott,
which has nothing to do with or fighting
about a poleward or someone who's
trying to be a poet and
his wife and stuff. Uh,
but this very interesting
history behind this story. Um,
and Mr Mrs. Elliott with the story was
first published in the little review last
time. We talked about how um, a lot of
the pieces came out in little magazines,
right? So this is the
little review, um, 19,
24 and 25 edition.
Um,
and then it came out again in our time,
obviously,
um, the liver right addition,
uh, the American edition 1925.
Um,
and it turns out the Hemingway actually
has written very telling leather to
Horace liberal rate. Um,
can see it here. I mean,
actually I think that if you go to classes
for you to look at the image online,
you should be able to zoom in and actually
look at all the words. But anyway,
this is the transcript of
one of the paragraphs. Um,
as you will see,
I have revised the Mr and Mrs. Elliott
Story and entirely eliminated the obscene
image. It is a shame.
It had to be a change,
but as you say,
it would be a very silly play to get
the entire first book suppressed for the
sake of a few funny cracks.
In one story, Jamie,
he ran it in this original form.
This is still a little review
editor of a little review. Uh, Jane,
he ran it in original form and
did not get into any trouble.
Okay. So with talking about
a libel suit that looks like,
um, that, um,
legal action could be visited upon
Hemingway because of the story.
So what could be the cause for this
legal action against Hemingway?
Um, the title of the story
is suggestive, right?
You know,
Allie,
there's a kind of very important
name and both American division,
British literature, very, very
important name. Um, this is,
ts Elliot obviously are known
to having way they were, they,
they were in the same
circles. And um, and um,
both in England and also
in, uh, in France. Um, and,
um, ts Elliot with one of
the most important poets,
20th century poets, best known
for the pump, the wasteland, uh,
would go on in 1948 to win
the Nobel prize. So, you know,
major poet, um, and uh, he,
um, this is a picture of,
um, of his first wife,
Vivian and hourly this on the far
right and Vivian is on the far left.
Um,
and it was the marriage that ended in
divorce and with Vivian having lost the
loss of mental problems. So in
this kind of very, uh, public, uh,
dissolution of the
marriage were very painful.
Ashley when she was clearly
going crazy. Um, so, um,
it, the, the Hemingway story
isn't really about that,
but it's really making fun of something
that really didn't end up being all that
funny. I mean, there was a
candidate who ran this episode, uh,
into this alley is live.
Um,
but the way that having way
is talking about it initially,
um, is, um, is this, uh,
this is his version and as you will see
is actually changed the spelling, right?
Ts Elliot, just one hour. Um,
and so it was just to remove the
threat of legal action from himself.
I has changed the spelling of Elliot.
Um,
and this is the story that he tells.
Mrs. Elliott and a girlfriend
now slept together in the big,
muddy,
evil bad.
They had many a good cry
together in the evening.
They all said at dinner together in a
garden on the plane tree and the heart
evening when drew and Elliot drank
white wine and Mrs. Elliott and the
girlfriend make and they were
all quite happy. Once again,
you know, this is the happy ending
in quotation mouth in Hemingway.
Um, so, but you can really see
why this would, that, that,
that Ellie is at least ts Elliot,
um,
with contemplate legal
action, um, against, um,
Henry obviously the suggestion of
a lesbian relationship. Um, not,
um, really, uh,
there was nothing actually
in the actual life of Vivian.
Elijah suggested there was
a lesbian relation. Um,
she did have an affair very soon after
she was married to ts Elliot. Um,
but with a man, um, Bertrand Russell
actually a famous philosopher. Um,
so, um, there was this, this,
this is complete fabrication
on a par that Hemingway.
Um,
but I think that this actually possibly
something else there's mixed into this
story is the less than relationship
that starts this from being a tragedy.
Right? You know, it really would
have been quite tragic. Um, you know,
if the girlfriend had not been there,
but it's really this re triangle or
relation that enables Mr Elliot to drink
white wine and to spend all
night writing poetry. He doesn't,
especially wanting to be in the
same room with his wife, um,
and misses alley and the girlfriend have
many a good cry together in the Beckman
that you've all bear. Um, and
they were all quite happy. So, um,
Hemingway really, um, is in one
sense thinking of the historic,
uh,
ts Elliot and Vivian Alec.
But I think that he was also
actually thinking of another couple,
very good friends of his,
at one point he talks about a great
length in the Moodle or fees and other
iconic figure in American and the ratio
of Gertrude Stein and her companion.
Um, lifelong companion,
Ashley, uh, Lsb Tacos desk,
Gertrude Stein on the right and aloes,
um,
on the left. Um, and um,
Hemingway also makes fun of them in
the movie blow fees, but, um, he,
if I'm actually, if you guys have
seen Willie Allen's midnight in Paris,
um,
you haven't seen it,
try to see it on DVD, but that
goes through the, is very,
very important there as it's
really a mentor, um, to,
to have anyway, I'm sorry. Um, you
know, where actually thought of,
I'm showing this but it's still running.
So you know, we don't have it on DVD.
You show it. Um, but in any case,
if you see that Woody Allen movie,
you will see the go to Stan was crucial,
um,
both to other young writers, but
also the Hemingway. Um, and so,
uh, very, um, long lasting.
This was actually a
sustainable relationship,
the lesbian relationship FALive really,
um,
and happy as much as any
relationship can be happy.
Those were very,
very happy.
So I think that we'll have in
way is as is done actually, um,
to produce this, um,
tragedies slash comedy,
um,
is to compound the very unhappy ts Elliot
a marriage to Vivian with much happier
companionship between Gertrude
Stein and Lsb told us. Um,
and, um, he really wasn't thinking
of, um, live or from Gertrude Stein.
She was not mentioned by
name, uh, but she could not,
not have been on his mind. So it
was just a really interesting, uh,
kind of a capsule summary, actually
have a lot of American literature, um,
in there. Um, so I think that
that's really the connection,
uh, with, uh, chatter, NY, um,
Nelson most of the subject matter and
there's no ball filing in the story. Um,
but the kind of the tragedy,
uh, narrowly averted, uh,
turning into a comedy of kind of a farce,
uh,
halfway between comedy and saw us,
um,
that is the ultimate outcome of
their kind of unusual arrangement.
Um, and, but still, you know,
it doesn't rise to the level of tragedy.
Um,
and that's the most important
point for him in weight. So, um,
less move on now to the next cluster.
Um, and I should stop
here for a moment. Um,
and talk a little bit about,
um,
the kind of the straw analytic structure
that we'll be using for the next,
um, next set, uh, of,
um, stories and chapters.
Um,
but actually beginning with chapter
nine and Mr and Mrs. Elliott, we,
we're beginning to see a kind of a logic
of substitution so that Gertrude Stein
Alice be tacos a relationship
taking the place, the,
there's relatively happy relationship
taking the place of the unhappy historical
relation between Vivian and hears Elliot
so that Hemingway you can get to a
place where he wants to be.
Um, and so taking the place,
um,
substitution is a good
thing in their chapter and,
um, in their story, um,
we'll explore the many,
the meaning of substitution in the
other clusters. Um, sometimes it's good,
sometimes it's not so good. Um,
it's always kind of a mix mixture.
Um, but, um, on the whole,
I would say that Hemingway's is,
is much more interested in
comedy than, than tragedy. Um,
and I'm sort of going against Aristotle
and in fact, the whole tradition,
uh, western thinking about
Jaras tragedy is the high,
a dignified, very dignified
are a Greek tragedy. Um,
and that's what really ever sallowed
hotspot in the poetics is his attention is
really all given to tragedy. Comedy
gets about two lines in the poetics.
Um, so, you know, I think that, um,
tragedy just has the different
kind of sensuality to,
uh, to the entire western Canon. Umm,
but comedy arguably is actually just
as interesting and just as complex.
So,
um,
in the rest of the course we'll be
thinking about the ways in which comedy
Ashley is right next door
to Chaz today. Um, you know,
we have to rethink the landscape,
um,
rather than thinking of these two as being
on opposite ends of the spectrum, um,
to think about kind of,
um,
almost kind of like emotional
proximity between tragedy and comedy.
I'm not,
because this is a natural trumps dimity
but because the riders that we are
looking at,
um,
they tend to have that really kind of
interesting kind of thinking and mixing of
genres. Um, so in the next, um,
cluster chapter 10 and cat in the rain,
uh,
well first of all, look at, um,
one kind of substitution
taking place in chapter 10, um,
the horse and pick a door,
uh,
and then the cat and the cat in the rain.
Um,
I should mention that,
um,
there's a difference between
the picador and um, matador. Um,
this is a distinction that I didn't know
about before I started reading about
having way, um, is that the matador is the
one who actually stinks. You know, who,
who actually kills the ball, the ball. Um,
the picador his function
is to weaken the ball.
The picador never actually kills the bull,
so it was always a kind of a three step
ceremony ball by the time he comes up
Bullis weekend already, uh, by very
few sticking knives into him. Um,
and then they'll pick, the dog tries
to do major job of weakening the ball.
Um, and then the matador comes out
and actually kills the ball. Um,
and the, the picador doesn't actually
come out on foot. He's always,
um, on a horse. And, um, and we, um,
find out how Hemingway
feels about that practice,
um, about a picador coming out on a
horse and fighting with the ball. Um,
they web where the white horse on
the legs and he kneed himself out.
The picador twisted the stirrup straight
and Paul and hauled up into the saddle,
the horses and trails and down in the
blue bunch and swung backward and forward
as he began to cantor.
The Ma knows whacking him on the back of
his legs to Abrazo some terrible thing.
Ashley, this has been bad. It's been
banned in many Spanish cities, um,
because it's just so,
um, incredibly cruel.
And here are two images, uh, of, um,
that kind of substitution,
shameless use of the horse
as a shield against the ball.
Um, and um, we can see, um,
the expressions on the, I mean,
you know, they used to it, I mean,
this is done all the time.
This is not exceptional.
Colanders on part of the pig a door.
That's the, that's part of the game.
Um,
and uh,
but still it's very hard to take when
you're looking at it and, um, to,
to see that Andrea was actually
coming up right at that moment. Um,
and here's another image. There's
just countless images. Um,
all you have to do is to type in
pig the doors, Hawes on Google,
and you find all these
images. Um, so, um, is, um,
Hemingway, even though he's
a big, uh, Aficionados, um,
of the matador coming out and we'll
see his celebration of this one on one
battle, the train, the
matador and the Horse, um,
just finds this practice. Oh,
they're despicable. I mean,
this is really substitution at its worst.
Um,
and so he's talking about,
you know, this kind of, um,
just just kind of, um, you know, it's,
it's hard to wrap our minds around. Um,
you know, there's kind of completely
ritualized, uh, practice. Um,
and so that's what he talks about.
Um,
in chapter 10 and then in
cat, in the rain, once again,
there's no thematic
continuity, right? Between, uh,
the chapter 10 and the cat in the rain
about when that young American couple in
the hotel completely nonviolent,
um,
setting. Um, and it doesn't
seem very dramatic either.
In some sense it seems as if nothing
happens in that story. Um, but, uh,
there is a kind of interesting,
um,
way in which we can create that story,
as a story about substitution as well.
Um,
in the sense that the young way
does have one very emphatic desire.
Anyway, I want a cat. She said,
I want a cat, I want a cat.
Now if I can have long hair and the fun,
I can have a cat.
So the cat obviously is a
shorthand for something else.
Right?
And she's actually looking at this kitty
in the rain trying to hide from the
rain under the table and
thinking of the cat, uh,
and she says, okay, you know,
if I can have anything else,
I can know my own silver at a table.
I can have new clothes,
I want a cat.
But even those things,
eating at the table with my own silver,
even bad,
it's probably just a metaphor
for something else as well.
Um,
and so the wanting a ACAT,
the fact that it's such an artificial and,
um,
persuasive substitution for something
that she doesn't have in the life,
um, suggest that there is something, um,
this very peaceful story,
um,
does have something in common
with a very violent episode, uh,
in chapter nine,
and it really has to do with,
um,
with, with, with the way, uh,
we think about what is adequate, um, to,
you know, what we could call a good life
or a good marriage or, you know, good.
Anything. I mean, you know,
having ways and really thinking,
especially if this story is about,
you know,
what constitutes a good marriage of
what is absent that would make for a bad
marriage. Um, but it really is, um,
thinking generally and abstractly about
what counts as a good life or what kangs
as being a good a player in a bowl five,
um, and coming out and using your horse
as a shield that doesn't count as, as, as,
as married. Um, for
Hemingway. Um, so um, in,
in this case, um, is in the,
the wives,
if we think about the configuration,
she goes out in the rain and umbrella
opens up behind her and it's a whole hotel
made that opens up their umbrella
behind her. Um, she says,
I want to care, I want a cat. Um,
and in fact I'll just read
you the ending of that story.
Um,
someone not on page 94,
someone knock at the door,
Avanti George said he looked up
from his book in the doorway,
stood the made to how the big tortoise
shell cat press tight against her and
swung down against her body.
Excuse me.
It's just that the [inaudible] asked
me to bring this person in Europe.
First of all,
there's kind of a very slight substitution
going on cause I don't think it's
actually the same cat,
this big tortoise shell,
cat public isn't the same kitty
that she saw earlier in the story.
So there's one kind of almost
comical substitution going on,
but the more important stuff diffusion
in the story other than just wanting to
care for something else to stand for
something else is also that instead of the
husband being the emotional
support for the wife,
it is the hotel apparatus
that has substituted,
has stepped in and
fulfilling that function.
The hotel may is the one who
opens them rela when she,
the wife steps out into rain.
She wants a cat is the hotel
staff that brings the cat.
So it is, this is, this is, uh,
for me this is one of the best and most,
um,
memorable portraits of, uh, of,
of what's missing in a
marriage that is just done,
you know, in a couple of pages, um,
and done completely
through a third parties.
Right? I mean, so this is his
story about supposedly about,
has been the web as almost tow completely
through the parties to the cat through
the hotel may, through
the petrol money. Um,
and so it says something
about having ways, um,
strategy as well.
And this is really something to think
about for all of the riders is how to
frame the story and how
to populate the story. Um,
and the population, uh, of
what is in the foreground, um,
in the story isn't necessarily, uh,
the, the, you know, the center. I mean,
the housemate is front
and center in this story.
This story isn't really
about hope, the hotel me. Um,
but nonetheless she is in the foreground
as is the cat. Uh, so, you know,
what is really, what is
this story about? Um,
this was a good question to ask actually.
This is another question that is
related to writing papers. Um,
start out by thinking, you know, what is
this particular paragraph about? I mean,
you know, certain things I know
for graph, but it could be,
there's something much more marginal,
could actually be the real subject
of that paragraph. So, you know,
it's always a good analytic strategy,
um,
to go out. Um, you guys never thought
isn't mine. Is that my
right? Is that, yeah,
for some reason I just
thought, um, you know,
that would be really a big
embarrassment. Um, but, um,
in any case, um, so, uh,
well I mean, here's a little ag with
substitute or whatever. Um, but um,
so far we've been, um, talking about, um,
the clustering of the stories
and the chapters, um, you know,
really kind of going in and kind of
oblique direction. Right. You know,
it's not this,
the lack of emotional satisfaction seems
to be the main point in artist stories.
Um, that's really the, um, the,
the kind of the tragedy
comedy slash comedy, um,
is the lack of adequate emotional
resolution. There's just no emotional,
uh, resolution at the
end of the calendar rain.
There's no emotional resolution
at the end of soldiers home. Um,
there's maybe a little bit of emotional
resolution at the end of mister and
misses alley, but really
not, not that great. Um,
so the question is, um,
you know, is, is, is this,
um, uh, kind of a natural
resting place for Hemingway,
you know, is, is that the kind
of the emotional landscape,
um, that he feels most comfortable
with and that will be completely okay.
You know, I think that is, is a,
is a Bible way of writing. Um,
and you can have great literature
resting on precisely that very precarious
state of lack of emotional,
lack of full satisfaction,
lack of full resolution,
a black thing that Hemingway actually is.
It's a slightly different kind
of writer. Um, so he, he is, um,
quite, um, unashamed of, of going, uh,
to, um, to kind of, uh,
sometimes almost embarrassing,
extremely sensitive.
You don't want to show that this
is really what you believe in.
So it's embarrassing in this
sense. Um, but he's, he's, he's,
he's not especially
embarrassed, uh, about, uh,
about making it very clear,
um,
what he believes in and
what he finds satisfying.
And I think that's really what makes
Hemingway, um, what he is a very,
in many ways have very emphatic about
believe in about emotional space that he
would affirm and celebrate.
Um,
so let's look at chapter 12.
This is the combination that
shows, uh, that sigh of Hemingway.
Um, and, uh, it's, uh, not surprising
as back trouble fighting. Uh,
but this time it's not
the picador on his horse.
When he started to kill it
was all in the same rush.
The ball looking at him straight in front,
heating the ball charge
and Vallarta charge.
And just for a moment they became one
filotto became one with the ball and then
it was over falafel,
standing straight and a red hill
of the sword sticking out deli,
betraying the balls,
shoulders filotto his hand up at the
crowd and the ball rolling blood looking
straight at him, looking straight
over the lotto and easily legs caving.
Um, so some of us with
final glory, you know,
I don't think that I work and sing
the praises of bullfighting. Um,
but I think that just to think in terms
of what Hemingway is doing for him,
this is truly um,
sublime and satisfying moment for both
the matador and follow ball because the
repeated line is that they
became one. Right? So,
um,
they became one that is the
supreme ideal for Hemingway.
Um, instead of having
this, uh, she'll, um,
of the horse showing you from the ball,
you are in direct contact with
the ball and whatever you do,
um, you do it in other lack
of distance. So you know,
this is the contact close up that
the diminishment of distance,
um,
and the two of them really bonding so
tightly that it really becomes a kind of a
single unit. Um, and that, that this could
be a matter of, of any kind of thing,
you know, can be a mannerable, can be
a man and a woman can be two women, um,
can be you and the project you become
fuse with. Um, but for Hemingway,
um,
this kind of comes theat
lack of emotional insulation.
We've talked about, uh, the question
of insulation in Indian camp,
but the complete lack of emotional,
uh,
insulation between yourself
that and suddenly you feel
our way passionate about,
um, bad for Hemingway is the, is,
is the place that he
really wants to get to.
And all those times where he doesn't
get there, you know, you can see that.
Why is the kind of a frustrating,
a resting place?
And he wants us to be frustrated when
we can get beyond those places. Um,
so this is, um, kind
of, um, uh, a very, um,
the kind of the classic Hemingway,
a moment of epiphany of
achieving this union, uh,
where the thing that the ball that you're
going to kill and the fact that you're
going to kill this creature
doesn't cling to him.
It doesn't really matter because you've
achieved that union at that critical
moment. Um, so, um, this is, um,
we are not reading the Sun also rises,
but this is a almost completely parallel,
um,
moment in the sun also
rises, uh, Pedro Romero,
um,
killing the ball,
the ball charge as Romero of charge.
Romero's left hand draft the letter over
the balls and muscle to blind in his
left shoulder when forward between the
horns and sort of went in and for just an
instant he and the ball, we're one, right?
So you can see that that was one is of
critical importance to Hemingway way two
entities becoming one.
Um,
even though that the moment
of death and killing, um,
it's still important to achieve
that oneness with the world. Um,
so, you know, it's, I'm sure it's
romanticizing bullfighting um,
but it's actually one of the rare
public demonstrations of that happening.
You know, it's actually very hard.
I mean, if we think about this,
it's very hard to see two
things becoming one in public.
So for fighting is actually one
of the rare instances when, uh,
when everyone can be there
and watch. Um, so, um,
Hemingway probably was looking
for something like this, um,
and it's really more like
a band, uh, than, than,
than actually the killing of the board.
Then you can see why he would want
to romanticize something like that.
It was really completely,
uh,
choreograph in such a way so that
the violence becomes completely,
you ritualize.
Um,
and we don't almost don't see them
plot and there's no blood, um, in,
in this moment. Um, so anyway,
so for, for Hemingway, uh,
completely on desire to
get to this state here,
we're one. Um, so let's move on now.
And I have to say I've actually
like the big 200 river,
much more that than the bull
fighting scenes in Hemingway. Um,
this is a great story. Um, in
many ways the kind of a rewrite,
two part story, a rewrite of
crafts coming home, right?
So this is also a soldier's
home. Um, he's not a man,
his family, um, but uh,
he is on this trip, um, you know,
through a country that is not
really disclosed to us landscape.
We don't really know where it is.
We don't know where he's going
or why he's on that trip,
but it's a fishing trip.
Um,
and this is what happens. Uh, uh,
at the moment when,
uh,
Nate catches and nick this is the
same neck that we see growing up,
the young nick and Indian Cam and the
doctors and the other's way of now he's a
full grown man, obviously
and haven't been in war. Uh,
but coming back and going through,
um,
what appears to be a healing process,
but having great so and soldiers home
is about a non healing of perhaps,
you know, the trauma of war and the trauma
of being completely margin Olympian,
sideline of those things. Um,
we'll just keep hurting him.
Um, in, uh,
the case of big too hard at river is a
rewrite of that and it's very different
outcome coming out from that story.
Um,
and it has to do actually with those
similar dynamics to the bullfighting.
Um,
so nick cleaned them,
slitting the trout and they cleaned them,
slipping them from the vent to the tip
of the jaw audit in size and the gills
and a tongue came out in one piece.
They were both males,
long ray, white strips of
mill, smooth and clean,
all the insides clean and
Compaq coming out all together.
So this is his, uh, justice,
emotionally satisfying
as the bull fighting.
Not in the sense that we don't have to
choreograph moping the quite as dramatic
and beautiful as an eyeball five.
Um,
but to be able to expand,
uh,
the ritual of dying in one
piece to the trial, um,
that is, you know, we do have to
kill the travel. I mean, you know,
unless we're going to go without
any kind of, um, animals routine.
Um, so, um, the, um, the, the,
the travelers speed kill, uh, but, um,
the way the man of killing is everything
that there should be no degradation,
um,
in death that the Ashley,
the measure of a good life,
um,
is first your ability to offer
a good death to someone else.
Right? Yeah. We do this all the time. Um,
it makes all the difference in the world,
whether we kill Brulee or
whether we kill ceremoniously,
uh, with full respect for
what we call, um, and, uh,
it also makes all the difference in
the world. Uh, if you die a good death,
um, there's really no other
conclusion. So, you know,
it has to,
it has to be a completely
clean and satisfy and,
um,
both to the person who's going or the
art to add the creature was going through
it and to the person who's
performing that operation. Um,
so there's actually, um,
as far as I can see, um,
Hemingway is actually a very
affirmative, uh, writer, um,
at the end of, in our time, um,
in the sense that he's also revising
his long story. Right. You know, is not,
he doesn't get to where he
wants to be in crab story in.
So just home he comes back and tells
the story one more time and there's time
kicked gas to where he wants
to do so. Well, um, uh,
say goodbye to him.
Wait now and move on to a Fitzgerald
and the grid Gaspe on Tuesday.